Is "Halloween Ends" really the end?
And why does its star think the film will
make fans "very angry"?
Here's all you need to know before the big
premiere.
The official release date for "Halloween Ends"
is October 14, 2022, just in time for the holiday.
Filming for "Halloween Ends" initially began
in January 2022 and concluded a few months later in March.
Pre-pandemic, Blumhouse Studios had planned
to release "Halloween Kills" in October 2020,
and "Halloween Ends" one year later in 2021.
Of course, delays due to COVID-19 threw a
wrench into production, so the pair of sequels
were pushed back by a year.
Studios generally like to release "Halloween"
films, well, around Halloween — which seems like a no-brainer.
"You know it's Halloween.
Everyone's entitled to one good scare, huh?"
This was the case for the first five original
"Halloween" films, which all debuted theatrically
in the month of October.
The sixth just barely squeaked in with a September
29 release date.
This trend was surprisingly dropped in favor
of summer releases for "Halloween: H20" and
"Halloween: Resurrection," as well as Rob
Zombie's duo of reboots.
However, with the appearance of David Gordon
Green's new trilogy, "Halloween" has returned
to its classic fall schedule, with "Halloween
Ends" wrapping up the tradition by releasing
around the same time of year as its predecessors.
The 2018 "Halloween" film brought Jamie Lee
Curtis back to the iconic role of Laurie Strode,
and introduced two new generations in Laurie's
daughter Karen (played by Judy Greer) and
her granddaughter Allyson (played Andi Matichak).
Though this central trio survived that film
and made it to the climax of the follow-up,
"Halloween Kills" ended on a shocking note
as Michael murdered Karen just before the credits started.
"So many people are dead!
We're not equipped!"
Curtis and Matichak are back one last time
in "Halloween Ends," with James Jude Courtney
and original actor Nick Castle joining forces
to bring Michael Myers to life, as they did
on the two previous entries.
Kyle Richards is also back once again as Lindsay
Wallace, Laurie's 1978 babysitting charge
who managed to again narrowly escape Michael's
knife in "Halloween Kills."
Trilogy mainstays Will Patton and Omar Dorsey
round out the returning cast members.
Joining the cast is former "Guiding Light"
star Michael O'Leary as Dr. Mathis, a character
mentioned but not seen in "Halloween Kills."
Rohan Campbell of Hulu's "The Hardy Boys"
will also provide a fresh face as a new character
named Corey Cunningham.
The official synopsis for "Halloween Ends"
explains that, rather than picking up exactly
where we left off in "Halloween Kills," the
story will resume four years later.
Laurie Strode and her granddaughter Allyson
are living together, and there's no Michael Myers in sight.
We can assume that the movie will have Laurie
and Michael locked in a final showdown of
sorts — at least, a final showdown for this
iteration of the franchise.
As for the fate of these two characters, who
can say for certain?
In an interview with Total Film Magazine,
Jamie Lee Curtis, producer Malek Akkad, and
director David Gordon Green gave a few hints
as to what audiences might expect from the
final film in the trilogy.
After "Halloween Kills" focused on the town
of Haddonfield at large, it seems like we're
in for a shift, with Akkad revealing that
the final film in the trilogy will be, in
his words, "way more contained."
"What the hell is happening?"
"It's Michael.
It's gotta be."
As for Green, he went on to elaborate slightly,
suggesting that the final "Halloween" film
— which was originally planned to take place
on the same 2018 Halloween night as both its
predecessors — may be something fans won't
expect.
He told Total Film,
"I get engaged by doing something different.
If I was just going to be repetitive, I would
hand the reins off to someone else.
When you have that opportunity within an established
franchise, it's really fun to think about
how you can show different tones and perspectives
and evolve."
The iconic not-so-sleepy town of Haddonfield,
Illinois, is one of the most infamous movie
towns in horror history, and also one of the
deadliest.
While the original John Carpenter film was
shot in Los Angeles County, the most recent
"Halloween" trilogy traveled to the opposite
coast to film.
The 2018 "Halloween" was mostly filmed in
the low country of South Carolina.
The second installment, "Halloween Kills,"
was filmed mostly in North Carolina.
Interestingly, "Halloween Ends" was shot primarily
in and around the Savannah, Georgia area,
though not exclusively.
According to the film's IMDb page, photography
for "Ends" also took place in part around
Salt Lake City, Utah, a vast departure from
the east coast locations and the film's midwestern
setting, leaving fans wondering just where
the final installment might take us.
The new "Halloween" trilogy, beginning with
the 2018 film, is largely the brainchild of
filmmakers and longtime collaborators David
Gordon Green and Danny McBride.
Though Green and McBride were both new to
the horror genre, they were longtime fans
of John Carpenter and Debra Hill's original
1978 "Halloween," and opted to ignore all
previous sequels and remakes.
Green went on to direct all three films in
this new trilogy.
Evidently, even though they ignored all the
previous installments in the franchise, it
still reportedly took Green and McBride more
than 80 drafts of the screenplay to "get it
right," with rewrites happening as late as
one week before production, according to
The Hollywood Reporter.
"Michael Myers, loose, with a bunch of nutbags
in Haddonfield on Halloween night?!"
The duo of Green and McBride returned to write
the screenplay for "Halloween Kills" alongside
Scott Teems, resulting in a sequel that proved
more polarizing than its crowd-pleasing predecessor.
Green and McBride also co-wrote the screenplay
for "Halloween Ends," this time alongside
Paul Brad Logan and Chris Bernier.
When 2018's "Halloween" was released, it was
a simpler time.
The film arrived in theaters and then quickly
made its way to home video soon after, with
the second and third films in David Gordon
Green's planned trilogy being greenlit almost
immediately following its success.
Unfortunately, it would be another three years
before "Halloween Kills" would be released
due to the COVID-19 pandemic, with the sequel's
initial release of October 2020 being shifted to October 2021.
"Halloween Ends" began filming not long after
the release of "Halloween Kills," with a set
release date for October 2022.
With only a year between these two films,
Green's two sequels will follow an '80s slasher
movie tradition of immediate back-to-back
entries.
The earlier "Halloween" series even sporadically
followed this pattern for a while — "Halloween
II" was released in October 1981, continuing
the story from the first film, with the largely
unrelated "Halloween III: Season of the Witch"
coming out a year later.
In October 1988, "Halloween 4: The Return
of Michael Myers" was released, which brought
Myers back from his comatose state, leading
into "Halloween 5: The Revenge of Michael
Myers" the following October.
"Halloween Ends" is set to arrive in theaters
on October 14, 2022 and — as with "Halloween
Kills" before it — will also be made available
on Peacock for the first 60 days of the film's release.
The "Halloween" franchise is a bit complicated,
but most long-running horror series are.
Including "Halloween Ends," there are 13 total
films in the saga, though not all of them
are necessary to enjoy this final trilogy
installment.
The only movie in the anthology that every
other film tends to stem from is the original
1978 "Halloween," which introduced the world
to both Michael Myers and Laurie Strode.
This masterpiece has become an icon over the
past four decades, and no matter how many
new "Halloween" sequels or reboots hit the
screen, none can escape the shadow of the original.
The original "Halloween II," "Halloween 4:
The Return of Michael Myers," "Halloween 5:
The Revenge of Michael Myers," and "Halloween:
The Curse of Michael Myers" all follow in
the timeline begun with the original.
The third installment, "Halloween III: Season
of the Witch," has nothing to do with the
overall continuity, beyond the original movie
playing on TV within its story about killer Halloween masks.
Then, in 1998, "Halloween H20: 20 Years Later"
was released to commemorate the anniversary
of the original "Halloween," thus ignoring
all the sequels except "Halloween II."
This film would spawn a sequel of its own
— "Halloween Resurrection" — which would
soon be ignored by Rob Zombie's two "Halloween"
reboot films beginning in 2007.
"Michael, you know I'm not really here."
"Halloween Ends" fits in a timeline composed
of the original 1978 film, the 2018 "Halloween,"
and "Halloween Kills."
This effectively sets aside all the convoluted
sequel plot threads concerning secret familial
relationships and ancient cults, instead focusing
in on the pure slasher element of an unknowable
killer and his tenacious prey.
There's no doubt that David Gordon Green's
take on the "Halloween" mythos isn't for everybody.
Removing the brother-sister connection between
Michael Myers and Laurie Strode was a gutsy
move, especially given that the vast majority
of the franchise has kept that part of their story intact.
This makes sense, given that John Carpenter
himself made them siblings while working on
"Halloween II" and the expanded TV broadcast
of the original film.
Carpenter admitted to ComicBook.com in 2019,
"I came up with this brother thing.
It was awful, just awful.
But I did it."
Nevertheless, the 2018 "Halloween" revival
disregarded this plotline completely, with
Carpenter's blessing, opting to start anew
with only the original 1978 film remaining
a part of the story.
This alone was frustrating for some fans,
though for others it was a new beginning,
and one that sparked new life in an otherwise
aimless franchise.
According to series star Jamie Lee Curtis,
many fans might not love "Halloween Ends,"
the final installment in this rebooted trilogy
of slashers.
She told NME,
"It's going to make people very angry, and
it's going to be shocking because it asks
a lot of questions.
So that's all I can tell you."
Wherever the conclusion to this modern "Halloween"
trilogy takes us, it seems it will be somewhere
we've never gone before.
This might be scary to some longtime Michael
Myers fans, but the possibility of an unprecedented
and surprising conclusion may be just the
kind of uncertainty the "Halloween" franchise needs.
For more than 40 years, Jamie Lee Curtis has
come and gone from her role as the iconic
"final girl" Laurie Strode, continuously escaping
the clutches of Michael Myers.
Now, "Halloween Ends" promises, well, an end
to all that.
"Evil dies tonight!"
This means that either Laurie is set to die
in combat against Michael, or live happily
ever after once he's six feet under.
Whichever ending befalls our horror heroine,
it will surely be thrilling to see her story
get a definitive conclusion here.
Jamie Lee Curtis has implied in a video promoting
"Halloween Ends" that this is her last time
playing Laurie Strode.
She went on to explain to Total Film,
"I'm not saying something like, 'Oh, because
I die!'
It's nothing to do with that.
I'm talking about emotionally what they have
constructed.
I think it will be a spectacular way to end
this trilogy."
With a title like "Halloween Ends," there
are some pretty serious implications attached.
No doubt, this is the end to David Gordon
Green's sequel trilogy of "Halloween" films,
meant to be a love-letter of sorts to the
original John Carpenter classic.
With Jamie Lee Curtis evidently satisfied
with the film's conclusion and the plot seemingly
wrapped up here, it sounds like "Halloween
Ends" might actually be the final chapter
of the "Halloween" saga.
And what better film to end on than the 13th!
Of course, John Carpenter has his own thoughts
on the continuation of the "Halloween" brand.
Carpenter told ComicBook.com,
"If you take a dollar sign and attach it to
anything ... it will live.
If the dollar sign is not big enough, no matter
what, it will not live.
This time, I do not know.
They really want to end.
They're going to shut it off, end it.
It's what David has in mind.
That's fine."
In an interview with ScreenRant, producer
Jason Blum went on record and reminded us
that this is Blumhouse Productions' last "Halloween"
movie, and while that doesn't necessarily
mean that Michael Myers won't return someday,
their work on the franchise is complete.
Blum said,
"This is our last one and I think people will
be very happy."
So it looks like "Halloween Ends" is the culmination
of the franchise as we know it currently,
but that doesn't mean it's the end for "Halloween"
as a whole.